[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuántos de ustedes cambiarían su hábito
de bolsa plástica si les dijera que más
de la mitad de las bolsas que ustedes
consumen van a terminar en los océanos
cuántos de ustedes
estarían dispuestos a utilizar un kit de
secuenciamiento genético o sea un kit
casero para conocer su genética desde la
comodidad de su casa
estos kit de secuenciamiento 2 genéticos
posiblemente les podrían dar información
valiosa acerca de sus ancestros además
de poder conocer su información de salud
con respecto a algún riesgo que puedan
llegar a desarrollar en su futuro
cercano o lejano pero cuántos de ustedes
que levantaron la mano también estarían
dispuestos a someterse a una
intervención quirúrgica para corregir en
su genética lo que saliera en ese
reporte
levanten la mano
qué tal si le dijera que esa
intervención que podrían hacer se les va
a garantizar que puedan llegar a una
edad adulta sin ninguna enfermedad
ya lo empiezan a pensar verdad saluda y
qué tal si les dijera que es el mismo
procedimiento se podría utilizar para
escoger el color de ojos de sus futuros
hijos e hijas
el coeficiente intelectual
su altura
algunos de ustedes quizás dirían eso
nunca lo haría nunca modificaría
genéticamente a mi hijo o hija por
atributos tan superficiales como el
color de ojos la altura o el coeficiente
intelectual pero qué tal si les dijera
que a través de esa misma intervención
podrían garantizar que nadie más en su
linaje vaya a desarrollar cáncer
aún así hay algunos de ustedes que lo
dudan
qué tal si nos pusiéramos a analizar la
forma en la que se están resolviendo
retos como el cambio climático
sabemos que existe la tecnología y la
ciencia para poder resolver retos tan
ambiciosos como lo son las sequías
desastres naturales inundaciones que
llegan a desplazar a millones de
personas pero hay algunas personas que
consideran que ya eso es un reto perdido
no hay nada que podemos hacer
por lo tanto lo más eficiente es irnos a
vivir a otro planeta cuántos de ustedes
consideran que la inversión en ciencia y
tecnología debería de enfocarse en cómo
convertirnos en una especie multi
planetaria
la realidad es que no hay respuestas
correctas o incorrectas lo que hay son
distintos puntos de vista y esos
distintos puntos de vista
responden a nuestra ética
pero en realidad cuando hablamos de
ética no estamos hablando de nada más
que un conjunto de valores y creencias
que cada uno de nosotros tienen
entonces que es ética
más allá de lo que yo considere correcto
o incorrecto lo importante es que es
ética para vos
y esa respuesta en específico es la que
nos invita a pensar que estamos en un
momento de la humanidad de los más
ambiciosos de los más abundantes y
cualquier cosa que vayamos a hacer a
partir de ese momento tenemos que tener
una consideración de cuáles van a ser
las repercusiones en el futuro cualquier
solución que se vaya a desarrollar desde
el punto de vista de ciencia o
tecnología va a tener implicaciones
éticas la pregunta es a partir de la
ética de quién
reconocen esta caricatura
a mí también me encanta
esta caricatura lo que nos está película
en realidad lo que nos viene a recordar
de una manera muy tierna es ese futuro
posible en el que podríamos vivir y
hacer referencias a cosas que ya estamos
viviendo hoy en día por ejemplo
estar frente a una pantalla la mayoría
del día solamente consumiendo contenido
y viviendo en nuestras vidas en el mundo
digital fuera del mundo físico
otra referencia que nos da una película
como wali es que la economía se basa
básicamente en la industria privada y
estamos constantemente saturados por
anuncios por comerciales por información
que está perfectamente diseñada para
manipularnos porque conoce cuáles son
nuestros gustos y preferencias muchísimo
mejor de lo que nosotros nos conocemos
por lo tanto no debe sorprendernos
cuando toyota ya está diseñando sillas
muy parecidas a las que salieron en la
película de walt
pero también los que nos presenta esta
película o esta referencia del futuro es
una posibilidad de un mundo
que ya no nos sirve como humanidad un
planeta que está repleto de basura
si recuerdan bien la película el robot
whaling s su trabajo básicamente recoger
basura
así que podríamos imaginar que esto es
ciencia ficción que estamos muchos años
de tener que presentarnos ante una
realidad posible como estas en realidad
el guión de la película está a 700 años
adelante de nuestra era actual
pero ya tenemos referencias de lugares
en donde es prácticamente vivir entre
basura
si esta es nuestra realidad voy
y seguimos pensando que estas
referencias de hollywood es ciencia
ficción entonces estamos dejando en
manos de otras personas que diseñen este
futuro en el que queremos vivir
y cómo va a ser ese futuro si lo dejamos
en las manos de las personas que
tradicionalmente han estado diseñando el
futuro pues entonces podríamos decir que
el hemisferio sur va a seguir siendo
desplazado con respecto al hemisferio
norte y que hay una mayoría de la
población que aunque es mayoría no va a
ser representada y va a seguir siendo
tratada como minoría entonces les invito
a que consideremos que en vez de pensar
cómo va a ser ese futuro pensemos cuál
es el futuro que quiero crear o cuál es
el futuro que quisiera co-crear
en ese sentido
algo importante que tenemos que
considerar es que no podemos resolver
los problemas que tenemos hacia el
futuro pensando de la misma forma que
cuando los creamos cualquiera de los
retos ambiciosísimo que tenemos de aquí
para adelante va a necesitar soluciones
innovadoras y esas soluciones no vienen
de un pensamiento tradicional vienen de
un pensamiento exponencial y el
pensamiento exponencial a lo que se
refiere es al mundo team king a pensar
que podemos alcanzar la luna como en el
69 cuando la misión apolo 11 logró
finalmente llevar al primer hombre a la
superficie lunar
seis años antes que eso había salido el
primer ser humano fuera de la órbita
terrestre
por sólo 118 minutos perdón
en el 63
la unión soviética logró llevar al
primer astronauta fuera de la órbita
terrestre por 118 minutos y seis años
después ya eeuu estaba colocando un
hombre sobre la superficie lunar un
avance de seis años
que se veía casi imposible ni siquiera
existía la tecnología para lograr hacer
este hito los teléfonos celulares y
ustedes tienen en sus manos en este
momento tienen mil veces más poder y
capacidad computacional de lo que tenían
las computadoras de la nasa en el 69
este pensamiento exponencial es lo que
nos invita a resolver esos retos
pensemos que para llegar a la luna
necesitamos un cohete espacial pero no
vamos a empezar con un cohete espacial
en la curva de la exponencial y dad que
la curva que ven en pantalla que
comúnmente se le conoce como la curva
del palo de hockey nos invita a pensar
de que todo lo que vaya a ser
exponencial va a empezar muy lento casi
que va a empezar en patineta
y ese arranque lento que es el mismo
comportamiento que creo que sigue en la
tecnología va a tener un punto de
inflexión en algún momento y a partir de
ese punto de inflexión después va a
poder llegar a la luna a ese punto de
singularidad pero como se llena entre la
patineta y el cohete espacial se llena
con un pensamiento bastante disruptivo
en vez de pensar en mejoras
incrementales porcentuales de 10%
vamos a pensar 10 veces más grande
si yo les pidiera que mejoraran este
salón solamente en un 10 por ciento
posiblemente ustedes dirían el aire
acondicionado la suavidad de las sillas
la luz pero si le dijera que tienen que
mejorarlo
diez veces más sus cerebros en ese
momento explotan se abren algunos de
ustedes pensarán que ni siquiera tiene
que ser adentro de cuatro paredes puede
ser al aire libre otros pensarán que
podríamos estar en nuestra comunidad de
las casas y estar aquí presentes nada
más en hologramas 10% es más limitante
10x es más sencillo esta fue la misma
mentalidad que la doctora margaret
hamilton en la misión de apollo 11
utilizó cuando diseñó el código de
programación que iba a llevar al hombre
a la luna
la doctora hamilton a segundos de hacer
el aterrizaje lunar estaban listísimos
para abortar la misión porque salió un
error en la en el programa y ella dijo
yo lo voy a resolver a segundos del
aterrizaje lunar ella resolvió ese error
de programación y gracias a ella es que
por primera vez un ser humano había
llegado a la luna
casi 60 años más tarde gracias a los
hitos el museo pinta el pensamiento
exponencial de la doctora hamilton este
año celebramos el primer la primera
caminata espacial de un grupo solamente
conformado por mujeres
yo soy
sin embargo seguimos viviendo en un
planeta
que podemos tener astronautas mujeres
haciendo las cosas más increíbles y al
mismo tiempo hay más hombres llamados
john en juntas directivas que todas las
mujeres juntas en eeuu que son miembros
de juntas directivas o sea tiene más
probabilidad cualquier hombre llamado
jon de llegar a una junta directiva que
todas las mujeres completas
y qué sucede cuando entonces empezamos a
incorporar
tecnología que tome decisiones basados
en esta realidad
qué pasa si un algoritmo se le diera el
reto se le diera la responsabilidad de
seleccionar candidatos seleccionar
candidatos con potencial de llegar a
puestos de junta directiva
entonces el algoritmo que no es ni
perverso ni bueno lo único que va a
hacer es basarse en datos históricos y
en los paradigmas y los aprendizajes de
sus pecadores para poder generar
decisiones
vivimos en un mundo en donde si un
algoritmo se le deja a la libre nadamas
basándose en información en datos va a
elegir a cualquier hombre llamado jon
por encima de cualquiera de nosotros
pero no es muy lejos no es muy distante
de lo que está sucediendo también con
algoritmos que son los encargados de
dirigir a vehículos autónomos carros
robotizados que no tienen conductor
en una prueba muy popular hace algunos
años se determinó que el algoritmo más
avanzado tecnológicamente
daba prioridad a un perro
cuando estaba sobre la carretera que a
un niño negro
o sea
si los dos se le cruzaban frente al en
la calle
y va a preferir atropellar al niño negro
y al perro
tecnológicamente era de los más
avanzados
pero el aprendizaje o sea toda su línea
de lógica y aprendizaje estaba intacta
el aprendizaje en sí venía de un sesgo
de su propio creador o de sus propios
creadores
de la misma manera pasó en un estudio
que se hizo en donde se le pidieron a
diferentes empleadores
que determinarán que tanto podían
reclutar a una persona basado solamente
en su primer nombre
todas aquellas personas que tenían un
nombre considerado remotamente exótico
como priscila
tenían 50% menos probabilidades de ser
contratados
lo más interesante es que ese estudio se
hizo en los 60s
ese mismo estudio se volvió a realizar
el año pasado
a partir de algoritmos con otros
creadores con otro grupo de
investigadores los resultados fueron los
mismos
tenemos que tener en cuenta de que
cualquier cosa que vayamos a hacer
desarrollar trabajar o inclusive
mirar y escuchar
está ahí porque alguien más decidió que
tenía que estar en ese lugar toda la
información que estamos generando a
partir de nuestro comportamiento digital
está siendo monitoreada para entonces
poder devolvernos diferentes estímulos
que vayan a hacer nuestra vida más
sencilla en algunos casos y en otros
nuestras decisiones más manipuladas
el futuro ya está aquí lo único es que
no está bien distribuido algunos están
conscientes de lo que está sucediendo y
otros seguimos ignorantes de que tanto
estamos siendo manipulados
cualquier conversación que quieran
continuar acerca de este tema estos son
mis datos de contacto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]